le temps c'est de l'argent et seule
industrie alimentaire le toujours
compris en nous proposant des plats pré
assemblés précoupés précuits mélange
agathe au tibet des nains en passant par
les conserves l'industrie a toujours
misé sur la rapidité d'exécution et le
côté pratique on nous offre des
solutions sensées mais on se demande si
parfois on pose pas un peu trop loin
l'argument gagner du temps par exemple
des smoothies en cubes sur joly qui
prennent entre 10 à 20 minutes à fondre
puis ses pommes de terre prêtes à cuire
auquel on a ajouté quelques heures dans
sa chair est un contenant le tout pour 4
dollars 50 alors qu'il pourrait vous en
coûter la moitié du prix pour la même
quantité de pommes de terre et d'herbe
où celle-ci simplement emballé dans un
papier d'élus pour 3 dollars 60 il
pourrait vous en coûter 1 dollar 50 sans
emballages superflus
le temps c'est de l'argent oui mais quel
prix êtes vous prêts pays